le concept de départ en fait était de
créer sur la zone et spa sud ce qu'on
appelle un tir lieu où espace de travail
collaboratif donc avec l'intention de
pouvoir accueillir à la fois des
porteurs de projets ou des personnes qui
ont un projet eau qui sont de recherche
de lieux pour pouvoir travailler et donc
l'idée c'était de pouvoir mettre à
disposition un espace équipé raccordés à
internet pour pouvoir travailler de
manière ponctuelle sur une courte ou
moyenne durée
l'idée aussi du tir lieu c'était de
pouvoir permettre on va dire aux curieux
de pouvoir découvrir le monde de la
conception 3d au travers donc de trois
imprimantes 3d pour lesquelles nous
avons été financé par le ministère des
autres maires et qui ont père qui
permettent en fait de pouvoir découvrir
les potentialités de l'impression 3d est
enfin on est aussi sur des activités de
formation et de médiation numérique ou
derrière on s'adresse à un public à la
fois de jeunes et de moins jeunes la
finalité en fait de cet espace est
surtout de pouvoir proposer un lieu où
des publics qu'ils se rencontreraient
jamais puissent se rencontrer et là je
parle de chefs d'entreprises de porteurs
de projets de jeunes et de moins jeunes
il ya des activités en lien avec le
numérique
trois ans après le lancement du projet
le projet on a beaucoup a beaucoup
évolué il est vrai que depuis 2018 on va
dire on a pris un tournant plus tôt en
lien avec la médiation numérique
pourquoi parce qu'au travers de notre
parcours on a fait un constat c'est que
il était essentiel en fait de pouvoir
accompagner certains publics en
difficulté face au numérique
justement vers les usages du numérique
et ça passe par
l' accompagnement dans les démarches en
ligne mais pas seulement on y était on
est aussi dans une démarche de monter en
compétences donc de ces publics